I have 30 pieces where are more
but I would like to be very such thing
in my summary of the main arguments the
demon is started with this Vietnam like
lawfare indeed even if it has to
accumulate weapons like officer tell you
yesterday mentioned and I may I read
some rely of the Wall Street Journal
February saying Vietnam has been
beginning bringing more weapons buying
more weapons and Korea and Singapore is
the eighth nation importer of weapons
during the period of - Oh 11 to 15
especially for novel and air force and
yet in my experience I have seen that
Vietnam tried to that used law fair
instead remember when food Cheung the
secretary-general call Beijing thirty
times during the the eyelid crisis to
try to negotiate as required by the
unclose before we're hoping that the
China will respond even if Vietnam is
preparing militarily with all the
vessels milling around the oil rig I had
the experience the Vietnam one law fair
mostly at first I am NOT a high gun but
high myself to go to not to attend
Convention on see boundary in Houston
Texas where I confront the chief of the
Chinese ocean an oceanic administration
who declare a very very early at a time
when you guys are accompanies here go
into this child such an icy you have to
respect Chinese law within the the
the 9s lie so I merely challenge him and
the the man cannot answer and the
chairman or dependent has to stop the
meeting to save embarrassment for the
Chinese delegate by calling for lunch
next thing is 2 or 12 in front of the
another big convention 20,000 people
attend but in one panel a deep the head
of the see and go see China National
Offshore Oil Company against offer to
the oil companies we can offer these
blocks in the South China Sea - for you
to beat and I raise my hand and ask but
these blocks are it in the territorial
not not territories at least the easy of
the other countries what how are you
going to answer the man can solve his
neighbors around the pandan table and
then say today we talk about not about
sovereignty but we talk only about the
technology or drilling oil so he evade
the question but I'm very polite at that
time so he has no way to to use any
other language than to decline only 214
in Da Nang Vietnam I was also this time
I was invited by the Vietnamese to come
there and I think I witnessed the the
urgent desire the Vietnamese to have the
experts in international law to support
Vietnam can position on lava they invite
professor here professor Jerome Cohen
and myself to the TV national TV to make
some point on the law for Vietnam so
obviously they like
and I will present the minute major
arguments for Vietnam but applicable are
available also to the other countries in
the region
I represent as in the whole I already
submit to you that the first thing is
the be legal basis for those territorial
rights and marathon rice no territorial
rice over those islands Paracel and
Spratly that Vietnam claim was based on
the classical customary international
law which say that the government
wishing to establish sovereignty claim
over land has to sell after occupation
its intention to make such a claim and
to continue administration in peace and
if joseline is taken over by another
government through the use of force it
has to protest in order to prevent any
new authority to acquire sovereignty by
prescription can that mean continuous
and this was exercise of sovereignty
I would represent surely them in Spratly
Vietnam discover under the French
colonial days six at least six land
feature and then continue to process
when it was taken over in 1988 by China
in one of the the of the rocks because
of that China cannot validate claim
under international law in the Rose
picture at the in the Presley Island
because they China was about two
thousand miles away from the Radley area
it's not in the within the continental
shelf or EEZ of China
this feature belonging to the
neighboring states in the continent and
share and they protest China taking over
the Paracels is more between Vietnam in
China and this has a lot of trouble in
the past because it has been subject to
many historical endow events but the
main Liza's Vietnam has been occupying
occupying and not at fully is mr. ting
mr. mystery yet but at least managing
the island since the the Emperor's in
1600 1700 and even the map of China at
that time in those employment eyes did
not recognize those area why the the map
that given by German culture Chancellor
Merkel two presidencies in pain stop at
the Highland Hainan Island so one can
say that China have more historical
facts to to plane and then Vietnam in
the parasail on both Paracel and Spratly
is a chinese argument that there was a
diplomatic note by prime minister from
random in 1958 saying a accepting joven
line declaration on territory to Mai's
mill limit at that time and this
argument of a check of the child Chinese
that because of that mean I'm already
gave up the claim on the parasha at
least and it was a lot of trouble for
Vietnam to answer so I wrote
and was interview by the Vietnam Press a
position paper on this in the rivet
Vietnam mission at the United Nations
used my animals in its website but also
more important more importantly used is
argument in the rebuttal against the
Chinese that adduced this foreign dome
decoration in Vietnam answer submit to
secretary Ban Ki moon so it has been
used the argument summarized in this
this three paragraph the note did not
mention sovereignty over the islands it
only say well okay we recognize your
tell tell my territory see because air
time Vietnam understand China worried
about the u.s. seventh Fleet right there
in one to support China but they never
mentioned which I learned belong to
China because it is China want to use
for mandamus attributing sovereignty to
China then what about the other island
belonging to Taiwan Taiwan itself is an
independent country at the time and even
now how can famine downside Taiwan
go back to China is this not here also
cider so Chinese argument is wrong the
not only top is only an electoral
declaration of man Prime Minister in the
lower echelon of the government that the
the esle on the level of the government
they can be clear surrender of territory
is National Assembly in the President Ho
Chi Minh and family is only recognized
one point on the territory and he's not
allowed to do the concession
of their territory that's a little
Hartmann more important those Island at
the time belong to say Vietnam by the
Geneva Convention the divided country
into 1954
it gave administration to the Brussels
and sadly to say Vietnam and Vietnam
being another country at that time the
the existence of two of the country of a
state is a question of right at that
time SAR Vietnam recognized by many and
recognized even by the Geneva agreement
recognized by China and novena and
Sabina administrating those areas and
thence the Socialist Republic of Vietnam
became successor after 1975 so Vietnam
as a whole never gave up claim of
sovereignty over those Islands even
famine down note has nothing to do with
sovereignty so and then after the
occupation of China of the of the
Paracel venom continued to process
through many years and this is part of
the international law continued process
over the illegal occupy protest in
1978-79 1980 81 82 84 88 90 90 91 90 for
two or twelve
so all these deeds and words defending
sovereignty territorial sovereignty make
it impossible for China to erode Vietnam
sovereignty by protection a great
reporting he was very pleased mistake he
said territorial this put in such an
assay is unsolvable in our lifetime but
even so I would say Vietnam has to
continue put process to preserve it
right to From Here to Eternity now talk
about 10,000 years
we can have more than ten thousand year
war at least under the law marry time
zone is UN Convention and closed and it
is as you say Vietnam right is like Bing
Duncan and me as a nail hit into the
column the wooden column is as firm as
that it's written clearly and everything
is right sovereign rice clearly written
in the the convention for example
article 56 57 76 77 so he clearly that
anyone that like China that drawn in
supply saying that this area of the open
sea which is the continent and shell or
easy of a country belong to China
those declaration is in violation of
other services and states claims of
territory systemize or exclusive
economic zone or continent ensure and
this exclusive rice is available without
a declaration it's always remained there
for those country to claim other state
can not explore natural resource in the
EEZ like fish oil or in the continent
shell of the postern state without the
explicit consent that's a hot allah say
so philippine can say you can have
soothes the soul because in our
continent and she'll unless we can send
to it
the within the enclose and within the
maritime area there is a very important
classical international law principle of
freedom of navigation which the u.s. is
not trying to confirm because they are
article 18 I say as I said yesterday no
state may validly purport to subject any
part of the Heisley to his sovereignty
at Miron General on the Ming Dynasty
when through the sea but no one way
travel and on the way back he died he
never claimed sovereignty by
administrative administrating any land
feature a long time all right now after
I made my I have made my arguments about
the sovereignty and sovereign rights of
Vietnam in other countries I hope to
suggest that we have to a peaceful way
to settle the problem China
violation eirick incident in two or
fourteen the China is a very astute
adamant in justifying the ORAC you'd say
that
it is place completely within the waters
of China's Paracels which is a very very
good 16 legal argument but I can attack
China position in two prong territorial
sovereignty over the Paracels
is understand the despot so it's not
it's not your lanyard and from and on
diplomatic note is nothing okay
so you go to International Court justice
to us about that territorial sovereignty
but of course
there is an optional clause I can say I
am NOT going to do that call but I
decided case international case that I
can stay so just we can go there without
China consent that prong two is easier
going to the arbitral tribunal of the
law of the sea the second lawsuit
Vietnam should pursue to ask for a
decorative decorative chadman about and
the procedure is compulsory jurisdiction
of the court
Elliott weapon in the Philippine case we
go then ask those land features and
though those area of the easiest
continent shall belong to the to the
coastal state not China and and it is a
declaratory judgment interpreting only
interpreting the Convention which is the
right of the quad to do interpreting
that okay DCCC and countenance our area
by definition with convention belong to
the coastal state which is defined
explaining interpreting the law we not
do not subjecting China to any any
penalty we just declared so Vietnam can
go there like the Philippines and China
can sit outside the coral and they still
can rule on the case because it is a
declaratory judgment interpreting the
law all right so that's the way we
should do the during the electrons there
are many other prongs I mean when Ernie
many crowns
I call it a pound the legal way to them
many mistake by China they China refused
to respond with 30 times phone call so
that they violate the in without showing
the article 74 83 was not so in
understanding incorporation
generally with valid freedom of
navigation by obstructing the area
around
oriT violating article 297 of an Plus
account number for China massive
violation of human rights of the
livelihood of enemies fishermen and
clothes would permit the fishermen to
sue China if the Vietnamese government
give give delegation that is such a
procedure private people can sue China
if the Vietnamese German youth say that
okay you guys fishermen being subject to
massive violation human right used to
and we support the next thing is have a
negotiation and conciliation yes I would
such support that is a very very good
thing it is actually the required stage
under Article two my eight of enclosing
and seventy four eighty three of enclose
we have to go through negotiation first
remember the thirty phone calls from
Vietnam to China trying to abide by the
law what about multilateral diplomacy
that means Southeast Asian country and
the other powers can engage in
multinational diplomacy with China about
freedom of navigation
how about joint development yes done
shopping said June 1970 is my Chinese
class Society spot join development all
right Joe development is an ordinary
practice already very common among
government and another business entity
from abroad will do it with the Chinese
if we want to do
can support aside his goodness all
everybody won okay how about sovereignty
will shame he was mr. Cassini tactic
will shame China in by saying that you
you have to justify you Zulu trans Iowa
sovereignty is yours or mine by
justifying that you supply I mean and
then other thing that you claim in the
South China Sea you have to justify with
otherwise you in other you do it and to
show that you have a is a big power that
we behave in a responsible way and not
as a lot less fun because good image and
responsibility is an essential element
of national power I think I would advise
Emperor China about about litigation in
the pole international justice
I have cited the article I mean to case
the US diplomatic and consular staff in
Tehran that case with that case body the
other case is advisory opinion on
Western Zara we can request an advisory
opinion for unclose we have compulsory
jurisdiction as I mentioned earlier the
arbitration award we coming soon I think
I agree with participant this foetus
China would not deny completely and
quick and close because they do beat in
Macau to the Chinese interest but like
China try to belittle the the very the
the Valatie of the so the other country
can use the victory in court as a basis
of negotiation to save the face of China
by coming to some cover
compromise solution with the or in their
back carry a big stick
but speaking softly like President
Roosevelt say the big stick being the
wall talking softly with China to save
China honor as a big power that's what I
suggest freedom of negation that already
discussed many times so I just
summarized in the area that the Chinese
bill artificial island there is no cost
legal obstruction or near legal
inhibition for the u.s. to navigate
nearer than Thomas because it's open sea
it's only there's a standard that they
can navigate away from those artificial
island about 500 meters but it's just
only for city safety reason not of
sovereignty reason then the last thing I
just want to mention is China cannot
have right of self-defense on the
StuffIt artificial island because under
the United Nations Charter only so
defend right if you have the real
territory which is not this case if you
have a claim of real territory then you
have the right to defend the NGA tauira
to set up ADIZ but nothing like that in
the summer slaw the last thing this
political intervention appeal to
international organization I would
advise everybody to appeal to the UN
secretary-general the General Assembly
even National Security Council cannot do
anything because anus veto thank you